all right daily wire has this report
Disney's latest agenda pushing project
is off to a brutal start at the box
office Strange World an animated film
featuring a gay teen romance opened
Wednesday with a poor 4.2 million
dollars in ticket sales and is projected
to bring in as little as 21 million
dollars over what should be a strong
holiday weekend the film which pushes
sexual orientation and climate agendas
is on track to be Disney's latest over
woke nightmare uh in fact from what I've
read they're looking at um
losing a hundred million dollars on this
on this film actually the wokeness in
this movie goes even beyond the gay love
story thing at the center of it uh so
here's some more details from the daily
wire report Strange World tells the
story of gay teen Ethan voiced by
jabuki young white
jibbuki is that the
how it's pronounced who has the support
of his loving biracial parents Searcher
and Meridian
family rejects its fabled Heritage as
explorers to farm but ends up pulled
back into the family business to hunt
for Searchers father Jager who went
missing when he was a child the searches
aided by their disabled dog and takes
them to
um avalonia a strange world with a
fragile ecosystem Ethan struggles to get
past as shyness around his love interest
a boy named diazzo so you got it so
you've got the gay teen with the
biracial parents
um it's a it's a story that centers
around a climate change and even the
even the dog is disabled like they they
even had to find a way
to inject some wokeness there as well so
yeah full representation all the boxes
checked everything is going for it as
far as wokeness goes right as far as
political correctness goes every single
box checked but what they forgot is that
you're telling a story and the story
itself has to be worthwhile it has to be
a good story and um
people just aren't interested in it and
so it's looking at losing a hundred
million dollars
one of the one of the biggest bombs for
Disney ever in history
I love spending time during the holidays
with my family and and one of the ways
that I like to do that is with delicious
meat from good ranchers as a special
gift to my listeners this holiday season
good ranchers is giving away two Black
Angus New York strip steaks free with
your order there are two 12 ounce
Steakhouse quality cuts a 70 value for
free you don't want to miss this offer
let me tell you why Black Angus tastes
better and is more tender than any other
beef black angus meat is marbled in such
a way that the fat is distributed thinly
and evenly this marbling gives it a
consistent flavor that you don't get
with other meats plus the Black Angus
from good ranchers is hand cut and
trimmed by expert butchers so you know
every piece is going to be Exquisite go
to goodrancers.com Walsh and use code
wall should check out for this special
offer that's goodrancers.com Walsh for
two Black Angus New York strip steaks
free with your order good ranchers
American Meat delivered and by the way
that so the people on the left very
embarrassed by this especially coming on
the heels of I've already forgotten the
name of it you know that's part of the
problem I think with the oh is it the
the gay uh
romantic comedy Bros so coming on the
heels of that and that comes out and
nobody goes to see it okay it's it earns
I think it was like seven dollars
at the box office opening weekend that's
not even a full ticket somehow just half
of a ticket was sold just half of a a
ticket stub somebody bought and that's
all that it did in the box office it's
opening weekend so that's a a major bomb
a catastrophe and then Disney tries
something very similar but targeting
kids this time
um and in terms of money lost it's an
even worse bomb
so this is very embarrassing for the
left and uh they're coming up with ways
to
excuse this and of course one of their
so that one of their go-to explanations
is that well this shows there's
homophobia homophobia the fact that
parents don't want to bring their
children
to go watch you know a story revolving
around a romance between two teenage
boys that's homophobia that's part of
their
explanation and the other one is that
Disney that that actually Disney
sabotaged the film by intentionally not
promoting it and that's why if any if
only everyone had been told about the
gay teen cartoon romance then the
theaters would have been filled
to the rafters with people just just
itching to bring their kids to be
exposed to this kind of content
but Disney sabotaged it and I can tell
you right now that is not the case and I
can tell you for two reasons one of them
is anecdotal which is that I definitely
saw advertisements for this I am not the
target market for um Disney films and so
many Disney films come out and I don't
even know about them
they they can they're in theaters and
they leave theaters and I never even
hear about them probably most Disney
films at this point I don't even hear
about them this one I heard about and so
it's anecdotal but I can say that if I
hear about it then it's definitely being
promoted at least to the level of other
Disney films and probably a lot more
than that
because this film got not only marketing
but it also got the free marketing from
the media
um
making a big deal about it because it's
a gay teen romance for kids
shattering the glass ceiling
foreign
so we know that's not true but also this
is not how movie studios work okay they
don't spend tens of millions of dollars
making a film
to then sabotage it on purpose
they they want to make money on the
project
so that is not the explanation the
explanation is that so it's it's not
that it wasn't promoted it's not that
everyone is homophobic
it's it's two things
one by all accounts just just looks like
a bad movie
where the message is put before the
story as I talk about all the time and
now we're seeing sort of the in a
Bizarro World version of the mistake
that uh the Christian film industry has
made for so many years where now the
message is diametrically opposite but
the mistake is in making the message
you're putting the message before the
story
so that
You couldn't possibly enjoy watching it
unless you're fully bought into them
you're only there for the sermon in
other words it's not that you're not
there for the story itself you got to
put the story first
um
that's part of the reason why I bombed
and then and then also as far as the
message
this is not a message that most parents
are interested in exposing their
children to
it's just as simple as that
and you can complain about it all you
want
one thing you notice that most of the
people complaining about it are not
parents
so most of the people insisting that we
as parents should be eager to expose our
kids to gay teen romance
so there's nothing wrong with that as a
parent what are you talking about most
people saying that aren't they don't
have kids
they have no idea what they're talking
about
and even if they do have kids well I
feel sorry for their own kids but that's
not going to affect what I do with mine
and the simple reality is that most
people even people who would identify
themselves as liberal they vote Democrat
I mean the box office receipts show it
even most of those people
when push comes to shove they actually
don't want to sit in the theater with
their seven-year-old kid to watch a
story about a teenage boy that falls in
love with another teenage boy
don't want to see it
nor should they want to and I'll do it
for this portion of the show as you move
over to members block hope to see you
there if not talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]